stoics you know Marcus Aurelius people
all know Marcus Aurelius from the movies
right and Marcus really it's the what
the stoic said is look the problem we
are is what what we set our hearts on
what we what we identify with right like
we're always assuming and assigning
identities for example right now I'm
assuming the identity of like you know
this academic person I'm assigning an
identity to you but this isn't the
identity I would have with my partner
when I go home at night that would be
weird right and I wouldn't assign the
whoa sorry are you going to interview me
now right right that's weird right and
so we're always assuming and assigning
identities and we're doing this in this
interlocking manner that agent Arena way
but here's the thing most of the time we
do this unconsciously we do it
mindlessly yeah automatically reactively
and so we set our we identify with the
wrong things and so what the stock said
is I'm going to use I'm gonna I know
your viewers can see I'm drawing a
horizontal line we identify with
horizontal things we identify with
trying to extend our life have more Fame
have more power and they said that's
ultimately doomed you're pitting
yourself against the universe you're
very the universe is going to crush you
yeah
instead go vertical Seneca said even
when you're painted into a corner you
can jump into the sky hmm so the
vertical is don't try and get the most
extension of your life try and get the
greatest depth there's a there's a book
wow that's so pal that's really really
cool yeah and so you live that and you
try and realize that now they did this
and uh even when you're painting a
corner you can jump into the sky yeah
and so things people can do when they
feel like they're painted into a corner
they can help somebody else that will
that creates probably some uh and they
can get more in touch they can and this
is helping other people service is
definitely a way to do this you where
they can get think about they think
about this as that I mentioned earlier
people don't want a flat world they want
a world with depth and height to it and
you can you can you can touch the depths
of reality and the heights of reality
and you know of course you can do this
with mindfulness practices and other
kinds of practices and this thing is I
get a lot of questions people ask me
like hey man I'm in a tough spot right
now I feel like there's no way out what
do I do right now so that's why and a
lot of times I'll say to people well you
know try and be of service try and help
someone else it is
um get out of yourself you know we get
we get trapped in ourselves definitely
that's that's very that's very much the
case so that's what I'm thinking what
other things would you recommend you
think well so let's talk about this
let's let's talk about and um
I think this will have personal
relevance to you too and and if uh I
don't want to push any buttons
inappropriately uh but uh let's talk
about when people the one of the worst
versions of that which is addiction
okay and so my friend and colleague Mark
Lewis has one of the best theories of
addiction it's basically a reciprocal
narrowing Theory so so your world is
like getting really problematic so you
take a substance to
alter your State of Consciousness so
that it doesn't seem to be so
threatening at least for a bit the
problem you pay for that is you weaken
your cognitive abilities now when you
come when you when you weaken your
cognitive abilities your ability to
solve problems in the world goes down so
now the world's more threatening so now
you got to take the substance and now
you got to take more of it and then you
weaken your cognitive abilities more and
you see what's happening the world is
getting more and more oppressive fewer
and fewer options and there's you have
less and less cognitive flexibility you
left have less and less ability to move
maneuver in your mind to change until
you can't be any different and the world
has no future and that's addiction
you've reciprocally narrowed your way
all the way yourself all the way down
now I was having dinner with Mark lunch
with Mark Lewis and I said to him and
Plato's in the back of my mind because I
got this from Plato I said to mark I
said
well if you can reciprocally narrow
can't you reciprocally open
can't you
bring some flexibility to your mind and
that opens up the world you start to see
the world in more depth and then that
actually opens you up into the depths of
yourself and and the world and you can
reciprocally open it would make sense
yeah and that's what Plato talked about
when he talked about the the myth of the
cave you know and we turn that into the
movie The Matrix so right you can you
can you can wake up you can reciprocally
open up and what's what's important
about that is that's jumping into the
sky that's like a set the word for that
is in Greek is anagogue it means Ascent
like like when they're the the people
are in the cave right and they ascend
out into the into the real world well
let me tell a story right so this is uh
Julian Barnes wrote a book The History
of the World in 10 and a half chapters
this is one story about this guy dies
and there's an afterlife and goes to
heaven Saint Peter's is there oh I want
to do whatever you want and and the and
and the good place made use of this but
I won't do any spoilers about it but
anyways
um great ending they made use of this
and he you know he wants to play and he
gets and he plays golf and he gets the
place where can play with golf
absolutely the best every single day all
the time then tennis and then any
painting and then after a while he comes
and it's like
you know I'm kind of done
and he's like and St Peter goes good
good
think of what good he's the point of
Heaven is not for you to live forever I
always think of the line from Moby Dick
what is man that he should want to live
out the lifetime of his God right the
point of Heaven is for you to be ready
to die it's ready for it to cease to be
because you're Immortal you shouldn't be
forever and then stoicism is can you
live now so vertically
that you're ready to die not I'm like in
some stiff upper lip we misuse the word
stoic we think it's about being stoicism
is about Joy not pleasure it's about Joy
it's about this vertical jump it's about
this vertical like deep depth right can
you
have such joy in this way we're talking
about that you're ready to die
well that's a great question
it's interesting and then how would
people get there you know and how does a
man like you know how do people get to
that place today the responsibility I
think men are feeling a ton of
responsibilities right now yes it's very
hard and that's okay it's interesting
it's that's what that's what's being
brought on by the world and by Society I
think men are realizing that they have
to be the uh
I don't know if it's the ruler of their
Kingdom but they have to really start to
step up and be a leader in their home
and in their environment
I think it's really I mean for me
somebody that's been of help for me
um is Marcus Willis I mean uh so he's a
great stoic philosopher uh but he was
also the um the the Roman Roman Empire
he runs the whole Roman Empire he's the
last and perhaps the greatest of the
five good emperors and he said something
that you have to really let it
reverberate inside of you uh because it
really it he said many things if you
read his the meditation the meditation
chatty kind of yeah thank God yes well
the meditations aren't written to
anybody else they're actually so if you
the Latin to him yeah they're written to
himself so he's doing a spiritual
practice and this is a practice you can
do by the way and it it starts to work
but one of the things he wrote to
himself he said it's possible to be
happy even in a palace
hmm
right and that that's so interesting
because you you think the last sentence
is going to be even in a prison or even
in a desert island or something right
deserted island and it's like nope it's
possibly happy even in a palace and it's
like there's a way in which although all
those things that are catchy but don't
have depth
we can we can we can learn
and we can help each other
Tick Tock Han said the next boot is
actually the Sangha the community right
we can we can learn to discern
uh through all of that and and get to
that where we can find that vertical
um uh such that we can leap into the sky
um
I love that man I love that feeling when
you're stuck you're painted into a
corner that you can still leap into the
sky there's a way to find fascinating
reciprocal opening there's a way and and
and and let's let's be clear I mean you
have Marcus Aurelius on on one I'm not
saying still I have criticisms of
stoicism
um but you know Marcus Aurelius is an
emperor Epictetus is a slave the the two
poles and they're both saying you can do
this you've both they're both saying at
the extremes uh you can you can find
this
um and and they're not saying they're
not doing it like a Hallmark card yeah
right they're like you you have to you
have to practice a lot of you have to do
a complex Ecology of practices that you
not only do by yourself but deeply with
other people
homed properly and then you can make
progress on
doing this what we're talking about